Let's see how to deploy an ASP.NET app on Google Compute Engine
Go to Cloud Launcher and search for ASP.NET
Click on Launch on Compute Engine
Give your deployment a name, select the zone
And click deploy. This will deploy Windows Server
IIS, SQL Express, and ASP.NET on Compute Engine instance
Once deployed, go to Compute Engine instance
And create a Windows user and password
Note down the password
Also, note down the external IP
of the instance. Go to Visual Studio
where we have a simple HelloWorld ASP.NET app
Right click on the project, select publish and create a custom profile
Enter external IP as server and destination URL
Give a site name, enter Windows username and password
And validate connection. Finally, select "Remove additional files at destination"
Hit Publish. Once Visual Studio is done
your ASP.NET app is published to Google Cloud Compute Engine